*Ouverture de la porte*
Heyyyyy
*Claquement de main*
Aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour une nouvelle petite vidéo
C'est comme ça que tu m'imites en fait
et comment ça va et du coup il m'a rendu ridicule en m'imitant si bien putain les amis comment allez-vous moi ça va extrêmement bien
aujourd'hui attention je l'annonce pour pas que des gens reste jusqu'à la fin en espérant rigoler c'est une vidéo
blabla mais j'ai envie de vous parler un peu à coeur ouvert et en plus j'ai des trucs très
important à vous dire alors ce qui reste vous n'allez pas être déçus
pour ceux qu'ils savent pas y'a pas longtemps j'ai fait une sorte de casting où je demandais aux gens d'envoyer des vidéos d'eux qu'ils se
présentent pour que peut-être j'aille par surprise leur rendent visite
chez eux il ya eu huit gagnants de ce concours il y en a eu 1 à paris un à nantes
1 à Marseille 1 en suisse 1 en belgique en
guadeloupe et un au canada et un au Maroc vous comprenez pourquoi je suis fatigué c'est que j'ai enchaîné toutes ces destinations
d'affilée pendant quinze jours à prendre des avions presque tous les jours à attendre
d'innombrables heures dans ces putains d'aéroports de merde j'ai accumulé au taux de fatigue qui est
légendaire mais d'un autre côté j'ai vécu le truc le plus incroyable
de ma vie c'est sûr et certain alors pourquoi je fais cette vidéo blabla que j'ai deux choses à vous dire une bonne et une
mauvaise nouvelle la mauvaise c'est que en revenant du maroc j'ai compris que mes lèvres avaient pris un gros coup de sec
donc je dois les hydrater toutes les heures
et la bonne
la mauvaise nouvelle n'est pas par vraiment une mauvaise nouvelle en fait c'est un mal pour un grand bien c'est que cette année je prends des vacances
mec oui oui et ça fait très longtemps que j'ai pas pris des vacances
enfin si j'en avais pris je crois il ya deux ans une
semaine mais à chaque fois comme je vous ai dit je me force à faire des vidéos d'avance parce que j'ai peur de rien mettre en
ligne parce que j'avais peur qu'on m'oublie j'avais peur de plus être au top chez pas quoi les peurs de merde de youtuber je
vous assure et youtuber sont angoissés en vrai beaucoup
de ça mais cette année voilà je me bats contre ce truc là et je décide de vraiment prendre des vacances parce que je trouve
que les derniers mois ont été géniaux j'ai fait plein de choses géniales j'ai découvert des trucs géniaux j'ai parlé de truc qui me font
kiffer en fait c'est des mois où j'ai été vraiment parfaitement sincère donc je peux partir en vacances en étant en paix avec moi même
en gros je prends un mois de vacances c'est la première fois depuis sept ans que je fais ça un peu comme vous je prends des grandes
vacances comme vous sauf que
j'avais j'ai toujours un peu d'avance sur mon planning de vidéos donc en fait les vidéos s'arrêteront vers le 12 ou 15 août je
crois donc en fait vous aurez un trou de deux semaines et pas de un mois voilà en gros la mauvaise nouvelle c'est les deux
dernières semaines d'août il y aura pas une vidéo de squeezie mais la bonne nouvelle quand je vais revenir de mes vacances
la vidéo qui va sortir ce sera la vidéo des 10 millions mec la vidéo je crois que j'ai même pas relié ce que j'ai dit
au début a ça en fait la vidéo des 10 millions c'est ce que je vous ai dit au début le tour du monde où
j'allais faire des petites surprises à des abonnés à travers le monde
et puis après celle ci il y aura juste un best-of et ensuite ce sera les vacances pour moi quoi il y aura plus rien
après le best-of jusqu'à la vidéo des 10 millions d'abonnés qui sortira vendredi
31 août à 18 heures
bref une bonne nouvelle ne vient jamais sans une autre bonne nouvelle c'est pas du tout ça le proverbe il n'y aura pas une mais
deux vidéos spéciale 10 millions d'abonnés wouh
ne cachez pas votre joie yes yes yes en gros pour les 10 millions d'abonnés la première vidéo ce sera un clip musical
c'était génial à faire je l'ai fais avec bien évidemment
mon très cher binôme martin qui est un beatmaker et aussi quelqu'un qui
sait mixer bref un petit big up à martin parce que on en a chié sur cette musique
je lui en ai fait bavé vraiment mais je voulais vraiment faire le truc le mieux possible et je suis très content du résultat et apprécié
de la musique c'est subjectif vous pouvez aimer ne pas aimer mais en tout cas le clip ce sera les images de mon tour du
monde les plus belles images quatre minutes des plus belles images de mon tour du monde à huit destinations différentes avec huit personnes différentes donc
je pense que ce sera vraiment sympa je pense que l'image va vraiment bien
retranscrire ce que j'ai vécu en fait pendant ces quinze jours avec ces gens et la deuxième vidéo du coup ce sera en toute logique
la version vlog de ce trip de quinze jours donc ça va durer entre 30 et 50 minutes on a commencé par paris avec williams
je suis très pressés parce qu'en plus on a eu la chance de tourner pendant la finale de la coupe du monde
on l'a en vidéo on à ce moment mémorable on gagne la coupe du monde vingt ans après
incroyable on est ensuite allé à nantes la j'ai juste une photo avec charlène que j'ai rencontrés là-bas on est  ensuite allé en belgique pour rencontrer
noé et on a fait de la montgolfière je me suis bien fait caca dessus c'était très effrayant
je vais pas vous mentir vous verrez tout ça dans le vlog bah oui vous verrez c'est fou
après ça on allait en guadeloupe pour rencontrer kim j'étais jamais allé là bas j'ai halluciné de la
sympathie des gens et surtout des iguanes ya des iguanes partout et je savais pas donc du coup j'étais en extase devant les iguanes tout
le temps à partir de là ça commençait à être très intense et il y avait Théo qui réalise la vidéo et du coup
le clip des 10 millions qui avait des p'tits craquages on va pas se mentir de temps en temps comme le montre cette vidéo
puis direction montréal un peu plus haut pour
rencontrer samuel j'étais pas aller là-bas depuis les vlogs de août de l'année dernière j'étais très content d'y retourner c'était super sympa et puis même
s'il y avait une grosse pluie putain les québécois vous êtes tellement gentil c'est abusé on a ensuite retourné à
de l'autre côté du globe à genève en suisse pour rencontrer
laetitia et là on a fait du bateau j'ai vu pour la première fois le lac léman et puis j'ai ensuite fait de
l'hélicoptères et c'était fou mec j'ai hâte que vous voyez ça vous imaginez même pas c'est horrible on est ensuite allé à marseille
dans le sud de la france pour rencontrer
inès j'étais pas aller là bas depuis 12 ans je crois c'était fou qui dit marseille dit mer qui dit mer dit petit bateau
dit petit port aussi et on va pas se mentir c'est très sympa et on a terminé par le maroc on a rencontré une fille
du nom de rita c'était une journée incroyable j'étais jamais allé au maroc donc j'ai découvert une culture qui en plus est très différente de la nôtre
donc c'était hyper hyper hyper épanouissant c'était fou chaque moment passé avec chacune de ces personnes était très précieux et très enrichissant pour moi là
vous avez vraiment un aperçu de 1 % de ce que je viens de vivre mais c'est important pour moi pour justifier
cette fatigue et cette pause que je me dois de prendre là cette année et puis aussi bas pour vous dire que voilà la vidéo
de 10 millions enfin les vidéos de 10 millions elles vont être
travaillées elles vont être belle et c'est tout ce que je voulais je veux vraiment remercier les gens comme il se doit avec
avec cette vidéo des 10 millions et je pense que j'ai réussi tout cas je suis content de partir en vacances en me disant que
quand je reviens c'est cette vidéo là qui sort parce que j'ai beaucoup de retard elle aurait dû sortir il ya un moment on est aux
11 millions déjà
j'ai un peu de  retard je l'avoue je pouvais pas rêver mieux en terme de vidéo
spéciale 10 millions quand j'ai eu l'idée en janvier je me doutais pas que ça allait être aussi
fidèle à ce que je voulais en fait et aussi
bien foutu bien réalisé et voilà je suis très très content je suis désolé je fais un gros débrif mais je suis rentré hier
en fait au moment où cette vidéo et du coup j'ai encore le voyage dans la tête c'est hallucinant à part ça
ces derniers mois ont été
incroyables sur youtube
je pensais pas que ma chaîne youtube pouvait encore plus marché qu'avant et surtout pouvait encore plus marcher alors je fais moins de vidéos et
que je fais surtout des trucs que j'aime c'est assez dingue en fait là vous m'avez mis dans la stratosphère c'est
hallucinant et d'ailleurs je suis content parce que prendre ce mois de vacances ça va me permettre de
redescendre un peu de me reposer
d'avoir de nouvelles idées de prendre du recul par rapport à internet à youtube et tout et ça va être très bon pour
la rentrée en fait je suis j'ai jamais été aussi
stable dans ma vie que actuellement en fait ça fait vraiment du bien en fait les gens se doutent pas de ce que
un youtuber peut ressentir en fait en dehors des vidéos que même s'il est là il sourit tout doit tout le temps allait bien quand
tu lances la caméra et tout mais en fait des fois tout va pas forcément bien et ce que je veux dire c'est que moi là j'ai
la chance que tout aille bien et la redescente qu'on va y avoir une redescente parce que la vie c'est des hauts et des bas
je vais prendre une grosse gifle
mais pour le moment mec c'est
génial ce que je vis je suis très content je vous dis à bientôt même si vous voyez dans cinq jours dans une autre vidéo puis en
signant le best-of dix jours mais moi là je
j'arrête de tourner c'est mon dernier tournage avant un mois ça fait très bizarre
merci pour ces derniers mois
merci pour toutes ces expériences tout ce que je vis c'est hallucinant et puis je le dis tout le temps mais je me sent obligé
de le dire
c'est tellement important je trouve de le dire j'ai besoin d'extérioriser sinon je me sens coupable vous comprenez ça je me sens coupable de vivre ça
on s'en va Natsu  allez vient allez on s'en va on bouge
Ciao tout le monde peace